the head coach of Washington Huskies
football Chris Peterson here on the
program how are you coach I'm good rich
how are you I am fine what what what do
you do with kids getting ready for a
football season just mere weeks before
it all starts where where are you right
now in the preparation yeah we're uh
we're right in the middle of the you
know fall camp and you know we don't
have we don't have two days anymore you
know the n-c-double-a took that away but
we really hadn't done
two-a-days for the last couple years
anyways but the days are still very long
you know the kids get here in the
morning and they don't leave until the
evening time with all of our meetings
and film and all those things and so
we're just installing our systems and
it's a long hard process and we're about
halfway through it okay now let's talk
about I guess kids that are returning
your quarterback my longtime buddy and
compadre Marshall Faulk looked at your
quarterback Jake browning last year out
of all of them I'm telling you I'm not
just saying this because you're on the
program but you are on the program so
I'll tell you he thought he was the one
with the most talent for the next level
out of anybody think that would have
been four even last year's draft to
coach what do you say when you hear that
well you know we're proud of Jake for
sure you know he's such a he's such a
football guy and there's nobody that
really studies the game harder you know
really in my my years of coaching you
always have a handful of guys that were
just so focused and so driven on the
football thing in terms of how their
preparation would be whether it's in the
season out of season
fall camp whatever it is and he's one of
those guys he understands a lot of
football he really enjoys playing the
game and so you know all that all the
next-level stuff that that's that's a
little bit hard for me to know you know
I just know the players that we're
looking for who are really good players
for us that have done so much for our
program and that's Jake browning well -
what would you attribute some of the
statistical drop-off that he suffered
last year yeah I think it a lot of it
has to do with you know our emphasis
on offense you know we're always we
always talk about just playing to our
strengths whether it's for the whole
season whether it's for a game if we
can't you know throw the ball like we'd
like to then we're gonna run it more if
we can't run the ball then we're gonna
throw it more we just work we'd love to
stay balanced like most coaches would
and we kind of go from there the year
before I know we threw you know a
handful quite a few touchdowns kind of
in that tight red zone area and this
past year we kind of selected to run the
ball a little bit more and so there's
always like a bunch of different reasons
and so you know I think that's what it
is everybody wants to attributer to the
quarterback and he didn't play you know
like he was supposed to and expectations
get out of whack and all those things
and it really wasn't that I think it was
a it wasn't it wasn't all Jake for sure
but we'd like to be a little more
explosive in the pass game you know for
us to be able to take the next step and
so we're you know we're working hard on
that well you obviously it's it's
tempting to run the ball when you have a
kid like Myles Gaskin at your disposal
no question coach that's exactly right
you start throwing it more and you're
going oh we got this guy in the
backfield that you know he needs to get
the ball a lot and so you know you're
trying to figure that out like I said
game by game and week by week and and
what the best thing is to score points
and you know we kind of figure it out as
we go Chris Peterson head coach of
Washington Huskies football here on the
Rich Eisen show against Auburn right out
of the gate
that that is scheduled one would think
because you need to get something like
that in the win column for later on in
the year when you're trying to get into
a fourteen playoff would you agree with
that assessment yeah I don't I don't
really know our ad told me that's your
place I'm like huh you know we just play
they put in front of us and you know a
lot of times these games are scheduled
out you know a couple years in advance
and you never know how they're gonna be
and it just so happens that you know
Auburn's got a heck of a squad I mean
they really do all the guys I got coming
back and what they did last year
I mean they beat the two teams that
played in the national championship you
know it's just I mean they could have
easily been in the national championship
they really could up and they got that
team coming back so there's no doubt we
got our hands full right from the start
I think all coaches like to have a game
under their belt you know to kind of you
know work out all the kinks that there
always are in that first game but that's
not how it is so we better be ready to
go well I guess part of the reason why
I'm bringing up I'll just go straight to
the question then instead of just
cutting around the edges Auburn lost to
UCF and I would have loved to seen UCF
play in a playoff game I would love to
see eight teams play in a playoff game
what is your philosophy on that I think
everybody would like more teams in the
playoffs no question about it
I mean and you're gonna always have that
debate you know you put 18 well then why
didn't this why didn't nine get in he
but still it's just it would be just so
intriguing and I think everybody would
love that now that being said that's
easier said than done with the school
year with finals with how many games
these kids are playing anyways you know
you're gonna take a game away in the
regular season and you probably could do
that with all the money that would go it
you know of TV all those type of things
from a playoff system and just so you
know the powers that be would have to
figure that out I'd love to just see
some more uniformity in if we can
certainly in a schedule like you're not
playing USC this year and and then
there's that then there's a pac-12
championship game that I'd love to take
those championship games and just roll
those out and add a playoff game if you
you know yeah let's let's go right yeah
yeah that's what I'm saying
I mean you're preaching to the choir I
think most coaches would like to see
more you know more teams in the playoff
and that would be fun but it's so hard
like you think about the NFL you know it
there's they got the system there's 32
teams and you know they know exactly
it's all even everybody has the same
preseason games everybody has the same
you know division games you know of us
play an extra league game compared to
some other conferences there's just so
much more subjectivity in this whole
thing and that's why I think it's even
more critical to widen that that playoff
the tournament
because who knows if you're getting the
right guys and especially when it's only
for Washington head coach Chris Peterson
here it's funny you say thinking of you
know when when you think of the NFL a
lot of people think that the NFL thinks
of you coach
do you get phone calls from the NFL to
join well no not I mean not really
you know I've coached in college for a
long time and and that's kind of what I
do and you know we appreciate the NFL
really did we learn a lot from them and
but you know we really like the college
game mm and in terms of the NFL it seems
that the NFL is taking stuff from a
college game do you find more NFL people
picking your brain to the next level
there's always dialogue back and forth
for sure I think it's interesting that
there is you know there I think there is
more dialogue I think in the past you
know there was such a trickle down from
NFL and I still say they're always there
always is that you know in terms of
what's going on and you'll feel that
maybe a couple years later whether it's
certain blitzes certain schemes but I
think what the college game continuing
to evolve with all the run paths our POS
and the zone read and spread type stuff
I think you see a little bit more back
and forth with the NFL the other thing
that I see is the tackling thing because
the targeting thing has been such a big
thing for us and our guys get thrown out
of the games we've been working on this
for you know 6 7 years now of really you
know trying to take the head out of the
game and be a shoulder tackling team and
so now I'm seeing you know the preseason
games were more flags and all those
types of things but that's just where
the games headed and I really feel like
we've been working on this for a long
long time of trying to take the head out
anyways and so there's more dialogue you
know in terms of those types of things
as well a couple more minutes with Chris
Peterson Washington head coach here in
the Rich Eisen show couldn't help but
notice you had Ryan leafing to talk to
the team a cougar but nonetheless he has
a lot that has happened with him to him
and his lot that for him to impart we
had him on our show just a couple weeks
ago why did you have him in to talk to
your team well first of all I was
awesome
unbelievable talk
you know there's just there's we talk
about the one things I love about the
college game is you know we're trying to
develop and recruit the best players we
can we can find and hopefully put those
guys into the NFL but that's that's
really only half of our mission around
here the other half is really helping
these kids continue to evolve and make
sure and figure out how to do life and I
mean that sincerely I mean that's really
a passion of mine if you know talking
about these life skills and and the
traps that we can fall into with with
money with Fame with social media with
women with drugs and alcohol all those
things so we spend a lot of time talking
about those things a lot of time and
we'll bring in different speakers that I
think can tie into what we're all about
here and Ryan was Ryan was phenomenal I
mean he connected to our team he was so
passionate about you could feel like the
things that he'd been through and that
he's he's really passionate about
helping guys not you know go down that
same path and it was a powerful message
and I really appreciated him coming in
here and talking to our team because I
think our team got a lot out of it well
I'm wondering if he mentioned Tyler
mullinski at all yes your team he did it
did it came up it was it was part of it
so it's all kind of part of that whole
thing and our mindset getting off and I
mean we could talk for a long time we
talked to our team for over an hour but
but that was part of the conversation
and these are just such huge I mean all
this stuff to me is so much more
important than just football and we need
to be talking about all these things as
coaches I mean we can we can play good
football no you know football's as
important to me as it is to anybody in
this building but if we're just all
about football here I think we're
cheating ourselves or cheating these
kids that that's not what this bear
experience is just about just football
there's so much more and you know part
of that we're seeing more and more
depression and anxiety and these young
kids and not only and young kids but in
adult adults as well and so why is that
I mean it's just such an intriguing
thing to me like why our
seeing that and so you know I talked to
the experts here on our campus at
Washington trying to get more
information and figure out how to how to
help our guys and and then you know just
again you just seeing everything that's
going on you're kind of like a CEO here
right I mean when I say things that are
going on you're seeing what's going on
with Ohio State why didn't her band
Mayer know this why didn't you know that
do you go around to your staff to see if
there's anything going on with that you
just look people in the eye and say is
there anything I need to know I mean how
do you go through all of that coach yeah
I mean we talk to our kids so often you
know about you know just the right thing
to do I mean that's really what it comes
down to and you know people are you know
they're human beings there's gonna be
mistakes made but it's something that we
talk about and emphasize all the time
with our kids but I always say that it
you know it always starts with us it
starts with me
you know just try to make good decisions
every single day and so that's one of
the reasons I really appreciate talking
to our guys about this stuff because
when I'm talking to them I'm talking to
myself and then it's I'm talking to our
staff and we all need to hold each other
accountable and stay focused on them you
know on the right things and it's it's
very easy to get off track and and so
it's something that needs to be talked
about you know 24/7 sure you know send
this very least have fun too I mean it's
a game I think that's one of the things
we talk to our guys about that you know
we work so hard it's so important to us
we're so focused you know it almost
feels like practice reps are life and
death and it's like hold on here you
know we get this thing out of whack and
we lose perspective of the whole thing
it's you know I have days where I'm like
tonight but I used to like football one
day you know lose track of like liking
this thing and so we you know even
through the hard times we need to be
able to smile and laugh and you know
support each other and but we need to
enjoy this process so we should be doing
it yeah sometimes you just got to look
around take it all in I from Yuba City
you know right UC Davis I did my first
TV job in Redding California beautiful
part of the state they're just sometimes
just stop and smell roses that's right
no question and we did notice last thing
for you on your Twitter feed
occasionally you
tweet out the word wolf just a bark from
your from your Twitter feed and I think
I know what those are in relation to
they seem to match up with times that
somebody gets signed your your squad or
a commitment is that accurate
well it means something's probably
happening good in the recruiting process
that's probably just notice big barks
coming out from the Pacific Northwest on
occasion coach thanks again good luck to
your team and let's chitchat throughout
the season appreciate that at coach Pete
uw to check on the wolf's and more from
the Huskies football program right here
on the rich Johnson show the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience